cuál la ecuación es equivalente a 5 x 2
x 7 x 1 igual a 14 x me imagino que aquí
quieren que simplificamos un poco esta
ecuación para ver cuál de estas opciones
es equivalente vamos a hacerlo
comenzamos entonces con 5x menos 2 x 7 x
más 1
se cierra paréntesis igual a 14 x creo
que la parte más obvia de simplificar es
esta parte de menos 2 x 7 x + 1
vamos a multiplicar todo lo que está
adentro por menos 2 nos queda 5 x más
abrimos paréntesis menos 2 por 7 x va a
ser menos 14 x
menos dos por uno es igual a menos 2
y esto es igual a 14 x
vamos a seguir simplificando este lado
izquierdo tenemos 5 x menos 14 x va a
ser igual a menos 9 x menos 9 x
los dos esté más con este menos queda
menos y esto es igual a 14 x
y esto coincide con nuestra opción
algo que acabo de darme cuenta aquí es
que casi omito un paso aquí pude haber
hecho este paso de acá lo pude haber
hecho también de esta manera 5x
- y multiplicar solamente el 2 por lo
que está dentro del paréntesis 14 x + 2
y después podemos distribuir el signo de
menos en lo que está dentro del
paréntesis quedando 5x menos 14 x menos
por más es menos menos 2 que nos queda
lo mismo que está aquí arriba
veamos el siguiente problema
la ecuación es equivalente a 4 x 25 x
igual a 6 - 3 x 1 - 3x tenemos estas
opciones
este es otro caso en el que piden
simplificar esta ecuación tenemos 4 x 2
- 5x igual a 6 menos tres por uno menos
tres x
vamos a comenzar por este lado
multiplicar 4 por todo lo que se
encuentra dentro de este paréntesis 4
por 2 84 por 520 es menos 5 es menos 20
x igual a 6 menos y vamos a multiplicar
esto al menos 3 por lo que se encuentra
aquí dentro menos 3 por 1 sigue siendo
menos 3 menos 3 por menos 3 x menos por
menos es más más 9 x
podemos hacer para simplificar esto
bueno vamos a agregar 20 x en ambos
lados de la ecuación quedando vamos a
ponerlo en otro color aquí voy a agregar
más 20 x
y aquí también más 20 x
me va a quedar 20 x 20 x se cancelan de
este lado nada más tengo 8 y esto va a
ser igual a
6 - 3 y 3 y 9 x + 20 x es igual a más 29
x
ahora vamos a restar a ambos lados de
esta ecuación con un menos 3 aquí le
restó menos 3 a este más 8 y aquí
también menos 3
y nos va a quedar menos 3 más 8 nos
queda 5
3 - 3 esto se anulan y nos queda de este
lado 29 x que coincide con nuestra
opción 29 x igual a 5 nuestra opción c
ahora pasemos al siguiente problema el
costo total se en dólares para rentar un
barco por m días está dado por la
ecuación se iguala 120 más 60 por n si
el costo total fue de 360 dólares
durante cuántos días se rentó el barco
aquí nos están dándose ese es el valor
de ce así que podemos escribir que 360
dólares el costo total es igual a 120
más 60
n iv n como recordamos es el número de
días nos piden encontrar m así que vamos
a despejar aquí a simplificar esto vamos
a restar 120 en ambos lados de la
ecuación aquí menos 120
aquí menos 120 nos queda menos 120 más
360 en la diferencia es de 240 240 igual
a 120 menos 120 estos dos se van nos
queda igual a 60 por n ahora dividamos
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 60 va a
ser 240 entre 60 60 por n entre 60 esto
se va 240 entre 60 va a ser igual a 46
por 424 4 por 60 es 240 así que nos va a
quedar 4 igual a n n es igual a 4
rentaron el barco por 4 días
ahora vamos a resolver el problema 11
resuelva 3 x x 5 igual a 2 x 35 aquí nos
están dando los pasos que siguieron para
resolver esto el paso 1 paso 2 paso 3 y
pasó 4 en este problema nos piden
encontrar en qué pasos se equivocaron
bueno en el primer paso distribuyen tres
por lo que está dentro de este
paréntesis y tres por equis 3x más 3 por
5 15 hasta aquí está bien y aquí bueno
de hecho el error aquí es mío porque yo
no escribí bien la x es 2 x + 35 esta
parte no la modificaron así que este
primer paso está bien ese paso está bien
ahora veamos el segundo paso si yo
quisiera resolver esto yo hubiera
restado 2x en ambos lados de la ecuación
es decir hubiera hecho en este paso
tener hubiera restado 2 x 2 x
3x que es esta parte de acá más 15
igual
2 x 35
- 2x
estos dos se cancelan menos 2 x + 3 x es
igual a un x x + 15 que da igual y esto
sería igual a 35 sin embargo aquí
estamos viendo que aquí no es un x aquí
hay 5 x seguramente la equivocación
estuvo en el signo en lugar de restar el
2x lo sumaron y por eso tres más dos da
cinco así que es en el segundo paso
donde se encuentra el error este error
vamos al siguiente problema una cuerda
de 120 metros de largo se corta en tres
pedazos el primer pedazo de cuerda es el
doble de largo que el segundo pedazo el
tercer pedazo de cuerda es tres veces
más largo que el segundo pedazo de
cuerda y nos preguntan cuál es la
longitud del pedazo más largo vamos a
dibujar lo que nos dicen en el problema
este va a ser nuestra
cuerda un poco extraña esta es nuestra
cuerda nos dicen que el primer pedazo de
cuerda es el doble de largo del segundo
pedazo y el tercero es tres veces el
largo que el segundo todos nuestros
pedazos son múltiplos del segundo pedazo
de cuerda así que vamos a decir que éste
es nuestro segundo pedazo de cuerda
segundo pedazo y vamos a llamarlo x
entonces en el problema nos dicen el
primer pedazo de cuerda es el doble de
largo que el segundo pedazo
así que si este es el primer pedazo de
cuerda este de aquí y vale el doble que
el segundo pedazo que llamamos equis
pues este será 2x y nos dice que el
tercer pedazo de cuerda es tres veces
más largo que el segundo pedazo de
cuerda
este tercer pedazo que va de aquí acá es
tres veces lo que el segundo al segundo
lo llamamos equis así que ese será 3x
y también nos dice en el problema que
toda esta parte todo toda la cuerda
todo esto mide 120 metros
estos son 120 metros así que si queremos
encontrar lo que nos piden la longitud
del plazo más largo primero tenemos que
encontrar cuánto mide el pedazo x así
que escribimos nuestra ecuación como
el primer pedazo que es 2 x 2 x + el
segundo pedazo que llamamos x + x
más el tercer pedazo que ya es 3 x
esto es igual a 120 metros bueno vamos a
simplificar esto sumamos 2 x + x 3 x + 3
x son 6 x s es igual a 120 dividimos
todo entre 6 esto entre 620 entre 6 606
es 1 x es igual a 120 entre 6
20 20 por 620
pero esto es el tamaño de el pedazo más
chico es igual a esto y nos piden el más
grande obviamente el más grande va a ser
3x el 3 veces el tamaño del segundo
pedazo así que 3 x 3 por 20 va a ser
igual a 60 metros el tamaño del pedazo
más largo es igual a 60 metros y ya
resolvimos este problema vamos a
resolver el problema número 13
el costo de rentar una grúa es de 750
por día más 250 por hora de uso cuál es
el número máximo de horas que se podría
usar la grúa cada día si el costo de
renta no debe exceder los 2500 diarios
calculamos cuál es el costo por día
nuestro costo por día se no importa
cuánto tiempo usemos la grúa por día se
va a pagar 750 no importa cuánto tiempo
lo usemos más 250 250 por hora que se
use por h la h representa las horas y
queremos saber cuántas horas podemos
usar la grúa sin gastar más de 2500 así
que todo esto esto debe ser menor o
igual
a 2500
resolvamos esta ecuación de acá
vamos a restar 750 en ambos lados así
que es menos 750
750 que está aquí
+ 250 x h
menor o igual a 2500 menos 750
estos de aquí se anulan de este lado nos
queda 250 por h menor o igual 2500 menos
750 va a ser igual a 1750 menor o igual
a 1750 y ahora dividimos ambos lados
entre 250 dividimos esto entre 250 y a
la desigualdad no le hacemos nada pues
estamos dividiendo entre un número
positivo 1750 entre 250 estos de aquí se
van nos queda que el ahora es menor o
igual a 1700 se encuentra entre 250
vamos a hacerlo aquí a un lado vamos a
quitar los ceros 175 entre 25 va a ser
más o menos a 77 por 525 persona 7 por 5
35 qué barbaridad llevo 37 por 214 más
así que esto nos queda una división
exacta nuestras horas deben ser menores
o iguales a 7 que es la opción c